our families have been present in court
every day of the inquiry and listen to
failing after failing from all involved
on that terrible night of the 22nd of
May 2017.
we welcome each and every recommendation
made by Sir John to try and make our
country a safer place and to prevent
more families finding themselves in our
horrific position in the future
we were present this week with the hope
that our government and Emergency
Services will have at least begun to
change and Implement these
recommendations
sadly that has not been the case for so
many of them and phrases like we aspire
to just aren't good enough actions need
to be taken so that when this happens
again there is a very different outcome
and other families won't have to go
through the Heartbreak we have
some of the recommendations made such as
the Gap in bleed control training for
First Responders that was clear
following the 22nd of May 2017 and we
are astounded to hear that six years on
this is not still fully embedded within
the police and we call for this to
happen without any further delay
sadly we have little faith that changes
will be followed through and we publicly
challenge the services to prove us wrong
and that's that the government look at
changing the legislation for inquiries
to have the ability to monitor
recommendations at regular intervals to
ensure that each and every service is
held to account fully
we have found the evidence this morning
in particular to be absolutely
heartbreaking
listening to the evidence from the
Department of Social and social care
this morning make excuses as to why over
six years since our families were ripped
apart the changes that need to be made
to make venues safer are still not
happening was awful to hear
as the chairman pointed out this morning
the government are legally responsible
for the health and safety of every
person in this country and if these
venues are not providing an adequate
level of care to those present because
recommendations have not been
implemented then ultimately those
responsible for this failure including
the government should be held to account
our plea to the government now is please
don't forget us and our loved ones names
but do the right thing in their memory